in 2014 i watched this video
four years ago
uh
of you competing
in i believe your first swim meet
against your brother terry uh and you
came out victorious
not really
okay so let's i wonder
here's what happened
i'd research this thing because i'm
that's how i am you practice no i didn't
but i researched in swimming if you
flinch on that starter block
it's a false start you can't twitch a
finger
and because they would be doing that to
get their buddy to move or the guy next
to him you know so you have to be
rock solid well when we went terry was
leaning forward as the gun was going off
so he's moving
and so i was like no no no false start
no no no no and he couldn't hear me he
was already in the water and so he took
off like a bat out of you nowhere
for the end of the pool and couldn't
hear me and got to the end of the pool
and it was a down and back
well that's a hard thing to do with a
guy with no body fat and so he burned a
lot of energy and he come up on that end
of the pool and he was like where's
where's he acts he didn't see me
and so we stopped him and then he came
back and then we went another one and i
beat him
uh but it's the only time that
you know i wouldn't say that he was
tuckered out and that's a reason why and
i'll also say this we did a time
where we timed my race
the one i won
and then we timed his first down to the
wall
and then we timed his the actual race
where once he hit the wall we timed him
on the way back and he beat me
now how's that for being out that's
pretty honest that's pretty honest
accountable wow person
and i'm gonna tell you something else
getting in those shorts
those swimming trunks that's impressive
they are tight yeah
so is there
is outside of wrestling is there uh
a thing that terry got the better of you
i mean i guess this could count as one
uh that you're still really bitter about
that you need to avenge
i mean that's past i mean we he's got an
uno title we have uno
world championships he's got a uno title
i have i have yet to have one morning
star has two titles that's unprecedented
so there's only four trophies out there
and terry's got one of those and i don't
have one yet yeah it's still time
tom thank you so much for letting a
russian with a tie into your home
you